in today's Digital World cloud computing
has become a crucial aspect of
technology and business operations it
enables organizations to store process
and manage large amounts of data and
applications over the internet and hence
the demand for people with cloud
computing skills is growing rapidly with
a 23.1 percent year-over-year increase
with an average annual salary of one
hundred and thirty thousand dollars not
only that the projected cagr of cloud
computing between 2021 and 2028 is 19.1
percent this growth demonstrates the
growing demand for cloud computing
Professionals in both developed and
Emerging Markets so if you're ready to
take a deep dive into the world of cloud
computing this boot camp is a great
place to begin the Caltech cloud
computing bootcamp helps you become an
expert in Azure and AWS this in-depth
boot camp course lets you master key
Cloud architectural principles needed to
become a cloud expert according to a
survey 9 out of 10 of our Learners
achieve their learning objectives after
are successful course completion this
cloud computing bootcamp helps you
become an expert in designing planning
and scaling cloud implementations and
will also help you master the core skill
sets required to deploy dynamically
scalable and reliable applications on
Microsoft Azure AWS this boot camp will
cover AWS Cloud fundamentals this module
will introduce you to the fundamentals
of the Amazon web services AWS Cloud
platform and ensure that you are fully
proficient in identifying AWS
terminologies Concepts and benefits next
up we have designing applications and
architectures in AWS in this module you
will learn to identify services and
features to build resilient secure and
highly available it Solutions in the AWS
Cloud the next course covered in this
master's program is azure Cloud
fundamentals this module will provide
foundational level knowledge of azure
Concepts Azure Services Solutions and
management tools General Security and
network security governance and
compliance features Azure cost
management and service level agreements
coming to the next module Implement
manage and monitor on Azure environment
in this course you will learn how to
manage Azure subscriptions secure
identities and Minister the
infrastructure configure virtual
networking connect Azure and on-premises
sites manage Network traffic Implement
Storage Solutions and more next we have
design infrastructure Solutions on Azure
in this module you will learn how to
design infrastructure Solutions we will
cover topics such as governance compute
application architecture storage data
integration authentication networks
business continuity and migrations and
the final one is the cloud computing
Capstone project this cloud computing
Capstone project will give you an
opportunity to to implement the skills
you learned throughout this cloud
computing boot camp through dedicated
mentoring sessions you'll learn how to
solve a real-world industry aligned
Cloud problem along with these there
will be a cloud computing bootcamp
master class in which the experts will
respond to your concerns so what else
can you expect from this program this
program includes live learning with
Hands-On exercises and access to Caltech
ctme instructor Caltech Circle
membership and quarterly campus
engagement earn a cloud computing boot
camp certificate and up to 15 CEUs
credits from Caltech ctme one-to-one
mentoring and resume writing access to
three million plus jobs via our network
of 15 000 plus recruiters Caltech cloud
computing bootcamp is the first and the
only boot camp in the industry which
provides 40 plus Hands-On projects with
integrated Labs 25 plus tools and cloud
services dedicated support and
mentorship Capstone project in four
domains Career Services support
sandboxed Cloud Labs the online training
will help you with various skills like
multi-cloud deployment performance
testing database management web services
and API Cloud workloads Auto scaling and
many more you'll also get hands-on
experience with tools like AWS Lambda
Azure container service Amazon ec2
Amazon dynamodb Azure resource manager
Etc the program is based on an applied
learning approach that uses a
combination of self-paced videos upon
completion of this program you will
receive the Caltech ctme bootcamp
certificate these certificates will
testify to your skills as an expert in
Cloud so what are you waiting for don't
miss out on this chance to take your
career to the next level enroll in our
Caltech cloud computing boot camp today
and start your journey to become a cloud
computing expert the link is added in
the description box and the comments
section below
[Music]